voulons pas qu'un joueur présente la
finale de la coupe de france de football
à 60 premiers spectateurs et au
président de la république lui mai 1952
miss bordeaux finale de la coupe de
france
la rencontre est particulière c'est la
première à être diffusé en direct à la
télé en france
plus de 1000 postes de télévision ont
été vendus pour l'occasion
[Applaudissements]
malgré cette grande première très peu de
matchs sont ensuite retransmis en direct
c'est le point de départ des relations
tendues entre la télévision et la
fédération française de football pour la
fff
la télé est une concurrente qui vide les
stades pour le journaliste pierre
sabbagh
elle est au contraire indispensable pour
les amoureux du football qui on peut lui
donner la touche de balle de de l'avant
sans si on peut douter la réaction du
gardien de but sion puis la tactique et
le détail sur plus dans la réaction de
foule
la nervosité de larbitre l'erreur de
l'arbitré de touche et cetera on lui
donne plus on pénètre dans l'événement
et on permet au spectateur télévision
d'entrer dans cet événement la
mésentente perdure dans les années 60
les chaînes peste contre les matchs
retransmis en différé 1969 les rapports
foot télé se crispe un peu plus en cause
le match aller de coupe d'europe entre
varsovie et saint-etienne le match est
diffusé en direct
contre l'avis de la fff aux commentaires
un tout jeune michel drucker qui
n'hésite pas à tacler la fédération
c'est un match ce qui passionne toute la
pologne est bien que ce match sera
télévisé sur tout le territoire polonais
près de vintimille à 30000 spectateurs
se sont déplacés et qui te soir au stade
de l'armée ce qui prouve que lors qu'un
club obtient de bons résultats tu es
supporter en lui restent fidèles et
viennent assister à tous les matchs même
si la rencontre est télévisée
saint-etienne perd le match
cette nouvelle rencontre en direct c'est
l'épisode de trop pour la fédération de
football
nous demandons à nos amis de comprendre
nos préoccupations de comprendre que
nous nous rions nous n'aurons pas de
football représentatif sur le plan
européen de football compétitive de
football aux biens sans les grands clubs
que nous essayons de protéger réponse
brutale de raymond marcillac de lauzerte
f nous notre rôle à nous c'est de
satisfaire les millions de
téléspectateurs qui sont en france
les millions d'amateurs de football et
nous sommes comme vous nous n'avons
qu'une envie nous c'est de promouvoir le
football qui est le jeu le plus
populaire du monde est allé aurait des
loups à le faire et que pensent les
clubs de ces matches retransmis
gratuitement ou presque la vie penche
plutôt du côté de la fff
en témoigne le président de l'ajs
saint-etienne qui est formel le match
retour de coupe d'europe doit être
retransmis en différé 5 doit pas être du
miracle il faut rester raisonnable
direct non on l'a évoqué mme direct pose
des problèmes à nos particulièrement on
peut très bien faire un différé de
quelques heures par exemple à 21h c'est
peut-être possible
le match sera diffusé en différé
saint-etienne éliminé de la coupe
d'europe il faudra attendre 1975 pour
que les tensions s'apaisent
c'est l'éclatement de l'eau et rtf la
naissance entre autres de tf1 d'antenne
2 et le début de la concurrence pour les
droits télé
[Musique]